congratulations this is really awesome
you're officially a college graduate
that's amazing that you went back nobody
does that
I you know what I did I kind of never
really left school and my my teachers
like when I when I was taking a leave of
absence to start working until I do the
village and stuff like that I kept
saying to my teachers I'm like I'm gonna
come back I'm gonna come back I'm gonna
come back and right away I started
taking classes at an accredited
university in order to transfer to
eventually graduate I didn't think it
was gonna take me 21 years I've been a
little busy making huge successful
movies so yeah nothing they need to be
huge and successful but they are so
that's that's what I just think it's
awesome like my mom's a teacher so when
I told her I wasn't going to college and
I was gonna be a waitress living on a
mattress to be a singer it wasn't the
best thing she'd ever heard she wasn't
very excited about the notion so it
worked out luckily but how do you
celebrate cuz so many things like I had
my birthday in quarantine everybody's
had like moments anniversary stuff like
that happening in quarantine how did you
celebrate graduating you know what it
was it was really kind of amazing like
my parents got one of those things one
of those signs that you can like like
put in the grass in front of your house
it's like like congratulations graduate
rice or whatever a graduate and um and I
had a my husband sent off um this thing
called like tribute where you can just
like record tributes for people and so
he sent it to like all of my friends and
family and folks that I've known forever
and ever and ever and they all recorded
videos um just you know being lovely and
congratulate you me and so that's really
sweet
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going